[Musique]
les cats a mis six déjà comparé aux amis
les quatre amis vous diront les objets
de la vie si tous kankan et astucieux
peine
déjà ligne
c'est le plus sérieux
les cas ça me va vite à jouer
aujourd'hui il suffit de vouloir devenir
un ami
[Musique]
bojan fabrice bonjour ça va bien fx bas
qu'est ce qui se passe
1 qu'est ce qui passe à quel point notre
demande alors qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
et parce que nous allons faire c'est
d'abord dire bonjour à tous nos amis oui
bonjour les monolithes isami google
voilà
ensuite le jeu de la géographie why even
ont révisé le contour le contour du pays
son drapeau et bonjour dans la langue du
pays oui et puis et puis après on verra
on fera la suite de l'émission un banc
très bien alors je commence si tu le
veux bien par le contour du pays salade
art géographiques où le capital est ici
c'est pas la capitale de ce pays est là
bien si oui ça c'est un set c'est un
pays qui n'est pas au bord de la mer 1,7
à noter ce doit être un pays d'europe
centrale ça je pense peut-être c'est
bien vous voir le drapeau pour ce allant
voir le dren oui voilà ce drapeau a une
forme assez particulière tu dois vous
permettre de le reconnaître aisément
même si vous n'avez pas la couleur
je signerais tout de même que ici nous
avons le bleu ici le blanc est ici le
rouge
bon j'ai beaucoup de bleu blanc rouge
dans les drapeaux a très souvent très en
vain mais c'est vrai très souvent nous
avons ça et alors là nous avons le bon
jour dans la langue du pays
seulement il faudrait savoir exactement
de quelle langue il s'agit je pense
aubry 2 brides yens que larry diène de
bridgend aubry bien oui et ce doit être
écoute si chimiques tu veux dire que
l'on vous demande pardon oui il y as je
suis moi même de ce pays et il y a une
petite faute d'orthographe ah bon à
double amis chez y dans notre langue à
part dont pardonnez-moi ap y da blues de
business de bridenne malienne si je ne
joue pas ne s'agirait-il pas de la
tchécoslovaquie avec un drapeau la
capitale et prague et je pense que il
s'agit là de la langue tchèque
voilà donc deux brides yens parce qu il
y a deux langues parlées si même un
homme trompe pas dans ce pays comme son
nom l'indiqué doit y avoir le tchèque et
le slovaque
voilà deux ans presque dans le même pays
voilà fabrice tu es encore le plus fort
c'est ma mémoire une bonne humeur il a
vu cet escargot qui a voulu me
ridiculiser en tous les cas il nous a
rendu service au graff
je le lui ai même pas répondu
actualisant disais tu sors balajo
restore veux me je vais retrouver les
autres 1,28 tiendront le jeudi
oui et du pré commun oui on t'attend tu
toujours henry m'a écouté j'ai tellement
à faire là j'arrive bon je suis prêt on
appelle fabrice rey fabrice voilà voilà
voilà
viens t'asseoir j'arrive mais j'ai pas
envie de me fatiguer mon coin attention
que ce ne soit pas trop difficile chez
eux
oui enfin on avait déjà dit ça le point
comment on rappelle tout de même un
toucan belles belles et pousse moussu
bonjour toi je peux parler de plus non
ce moment non non non non les laisse
parler les grandes personnes allons
allons son ca 30 tout à l'heure des
objets ou des choses tout le problème
consiste à savoir quel est le point
commun qui les unit voilà je vous écris
cela est bien leur - fabrice je suis un
endroit très apprécié des automobilistes
oui il me rencontrer souvent au cours de
leur randonnée d'ailleurs aussi bien sur
les autoroutes d'ailleurs que sur les
nationales 1 et je suis un peu plus rare
sur les petites routes de campagne ça
c'est vrai mais on ne rencontre aussi à
la sortie ou à la rentrée des petits
villages et je m'arrange toujours pour
qu'on aperçoit de loin parce que je sais
que ça fait plaisir aux conducteurs de
découvrir ma silhouette au bout d'une
longue ligne droite tu vois d'abord je
leur procure de quoi tu continuer le
voyage je les rassure sur l'état de leur
voiture et puis j'ai souvent quelques
petites choses à offrir aux enfants pour
les distraire un mais je me tiens je me
tais parce que je crois que j'en ai
assez dit
les un petit peu alors moi fabrice tu
m'écoutes au début je dois aucune ne me
regarde pas et si je te regarde
alors j'ai représenté vacances aussi
bien les vacances d'été que les vacances
d'hiver
je rassemble eu beaucoup de monde autour
de moi et je m'arrange toujours pour
avoir tout ce qu'il faut pour les
distraire en hiver on trouve chez moi
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour goûter
aux plaisirs de la neige des skis drôme
aux potes du petit chalet des moniteurs
ont été sur les plages
je vous propose des promenades en mer
des planches aval des pédalos des
concours de châteaux de sable des
emplacements pour voto tvo caravanes et
des parts de jeux sur la plage avec des
portiques des ballons de la pêche sous
marine
alors j'ai une idée une idée mais je
préfère écouter maintenant la version 2
pouces conçu pour être sûr de moi même
ouais moi je vais te dire je suis pas
comme tout comprendre pas très utile
pour ceux qui voyagent
mais si si au contraire je suis je suis
très utile pour ceux qui voyagent mais
pas en voiture et non non je préfère
voyager en train on m'utilise aussi pour
pour les voyages en métro mais des
métros 1 y en a pas partout
alors ben j'aime mieux pas en parler
mais pour en revenir au train et bien si
je n'existais pas on ne pourrait pas le
prendre le train là si on avait réussi à
le prendre attention si on avait réussi
à le prendre on ne pourrait plus
redescendre et on voyagera erré toute sa
vie et puis ce serait enfin ce serait
très triste quand même j'aurais pu le
chef de gare déjà un peu plus de
passages souterrains
oui on est j'aurais que derrag durable
encore dire avec toujours des rails je
veux dire je crois voir je crois voir à
mon avis à mon avis tout quand on nous a
parlé d'une station-service belle belle
nous a parlé une station de sports
d'hiver
elle a exactement et bouge moussu d'une
station de chemin de fer vous êtes donc
tous les trois des stations est
astucieux c'est pas très agressif très
bon vieux c'est bien bravo mon cher
fabrice a tout de suite et j'espère que
tu seras aussi très astucieux avec moi
pour le jeu des notes musicales aura que
plus belle en tout près par le gem jeu
ça vous fait mes adieux à six coups sous
le soleil c'est à nous maintenant c'est
que ça va être à toi c'est notre jeu
fabrice tu as bien travaillé
oui oui je crois je crois que je vais
t'étonner là c'est vrai ah oui je vais
t'étonner par contre une question c'est
très difficile et maintenant c'est pas
près dé finale tu verras tu crois que je
vais m'en sortir
oui oui très bien où tu t'en sors
toujours très bien dans mon crayon à
j'espère que tu n'as pas oublié
alors je vois tableau tu vas au tableau
dès que tu me repose
eh bien je te propose un mot en huile
être hui les trois premières lettres la
la la première lettre
c'est un air air alors un deux trois
quatre cinq six sus dernière lettre est
la dernière à eux
alors est ce que c'est un animal
ah non c'est pas un animal est ce que
c'est une plante
oui c'est une plante tu vois tu as
trouvé est ce que c'est une plante qui
sent bon mais bon tu peux pas
spécialement m'enfin est ce que c'est
une plante qui
il se mange ben oui et non c'est à dire
que oui ça se mange jamais tant que ça
se mange assassinant oui ça va ça avait
une certaine partie se mange tu vois est
ce que c'est une plante que l'on trouve
dans l'eau peut assez facilement oui oh
oui rouina un peu partout pas dans la
forêt dans les champs et dans les champs
donne moi une lettre tu vas encore une
lettre ont dit non alors qu'est ce que
je pourrais te donner veux tu là voyons
voyons voyons là la deuxième la wii la
deuxième elle est la deuxième après le
1er la deuxième oui est ce que c'est
c'est un put à une 1ère sûrs u11 et rue
je peux encore donner un petit élément
vas-y avec cette plante on fait des
compotes et de la confiture et les
petits enfants aiment beaucoup ça avec
les rues oui avec un rhume de la compote
à des confitures et oui dans ce propos
c'est là si c'est possible pour son
esprit un tu m'aurais pas écrit rhubarbe
air rue mais chi rhubarbe
bah oui c'est écrit rue hb à rbs sera
toujours le désespoir de ceux qui
connaissent l'orthographe armes et
pourtant je croyais bien tu maire a eu
un bon y'a quand même un à ce jeu c'est
moi qui vais nager ou hamza et palmer à
bâgé pas de chance et secouru barbe
voilà comment ça s'écrit rhubarbe
non vraiment est ce que je trouve
navrant c'est que tout cancan depuis le
temps witt incapable de te donner le
moindre coup de main il ne révise pas il
ne connaît pas mieux en parce que toi et
c'est pas bon tout
21 oui qu'est ce que tu vois on ne peut
pas tout savoir savoir merbah parce que
je sais en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
que la rhubarbe c'est une drôle de
plante
oui parce que les tiges justement je te
le disais tout à l'heure les tiges
elles sont très bonnes mais les feuilles
elles sont très très mauvaise et mêmes
et elles rendent malade voire bon alors
il faut faire très attention quand on la
prépare
il faut enlever toutes les feuilles du
bas cet examen à huy bon ben je te
remercie de ces précisions tu te
rattrape toujours un petit peu à des
fautes d'orthographe
ce qui est bien mais enfin tu sais tout
de même et tu dis un peu et rival
sinon belle belle ne sera pas content
bell bell seul top mais je suis prêt tu
t'attends à fabrice qui a joué avec moi
[Musique]
c'est pas si la musique
la famille assad
sam max jadot la façade de l émir
seulement cinq semaines au fait t'as
l'habitude alors on commence qui faisait
pas on y va oui je veux j'écoute suis un
peu énervé j'ai une nouvelle
intéressante apte à prendre
oui oui je prends des cours du soir à
j'ai envie d'apprendre un vrai métier je
sais bien que ça va te paraître étonnant
de la part de quelqu'un comme moi qui
connais déjà tellement de choses et
dollars mis à huer le mans 2-1 du site
alors réussite
oui réussite si ça mais la première
répète un petit peu ce que tu m'as
d'olivier j une mine très charmante une
amie non in may eu une réunion à une
famille
c'est une famille est patente j'attends
de tous dans cette famille un oncle par
exemple les pêcheurs sur un châle y est
et puis qu à trouver sera quoi il est
pêcheur sur un chacun y est à tu veux
parler de la lettre u cha lui et ses
usagers l'ancien dod exactement aux
docks et j'ai aussi un cousin pons
cionet un cousin missionnaire oui il
aller prêcher la bonne parole aux quatre
coins du monde
aa je trouve c'est un fonctionnaire à
l'initial balle à un missionnaire
j'aurais aimé surtout c'est que mon
arrière grand père architecte oui à
l'époque on construisait en pierre
parent non c'est pas intéressant le
moment pour les maisons c'est le oui
c'est dégoûtant d'ailleurs seulement
c'est dégoûtant c'est très laid c'est le
froid le maudit dont celle ses 2,6 alors
le ciment qui suis dit la vérité
oui mais c'est pas bon oui des lotos
dans cette maison que je ferai
construire en pire j'aurai une grande
pièce qui servirait de salon et de sa
peut manger de deux salles à manger
salle à manger ya pas de mot et il l'a
alors qu'est ce que tu as fait tu le
manges tu sais que tu fais des genoux
maintenant alors ça devient difficile à
et puis d'en masse à la manger j'aurai
une grande chope pour mener une chaude
ou mener une chaude en bout haut la
traîtresse et j'aurai des fenêtres avec
des petits carreaux et je leur mettrais
du petit lit d'eau rideau émises à damas
et bien voilà c'est parfait je vous
avons joué nous avons été très bien
maintenant nous allons chanter
d'accord vous avez
les dates sont déjà aux papas les amis
et les quatre amis vous diront ils
secret de la vie majel désiste et g
shock c'est des chances
jenny batoumi noir il faudra faire
attention les cartes a mis son monde
racontée sans répit les caps à me
souvenir impérissable
[Musique]
oui
m
libre à crier au loup mais gagne et à
guy vous invite à jouer aujourd'hui
et si si je vous vois venir
azami il suffit de vouloir devenir amis
c'est vrai j'étais fatigué
[Musique]